Speaker 1: Let's go next to Eddie from South
Bend. Is that is that South Bend, Indiana?
Speaker 2: Yeah, that's right,
can you hear me all right?
Speaker 1: I can see what's going on,
Speaker 2: so I have possibly your first
ever multiple choice call. Okay. Well, on a
scale of one to five one being a super softball
question and five being what many are calling
the greatest indictment of The David Pakman Show.
So what would you like on a scale of one to five?
Speaker 1: Like in other words, you have five
different questions that I can choose from.
Speaker 2: Yeah, no. Number three is more like,
I guess a comment, but yeah, pretty much.
Speaker 1: Let's not go with that. Let's
go with a four. I'll take a tough
question, but not like the toughest.
Speaker 2: OK. So, you know, I've been
going back in your earlier videos looking at
some of your earlier opinion. Something
ever talked about in a while is sort of
representation and identity politics.
OK. So to some degree, there is, like,
I would argue, an importance to these sorts of
things. And I have a. A story, if you want it from
that. From an experiment, my friend did, but
in any case, I guess the question would be
to what degree would you sacrifice policy for
identity in politics? What do you mean by.
Speaker 1: I'd need to. What's an example of
that? Can you give me an example of what it
would mean to sacrifice polysaccharide entity?
Speaker 2: So let's say, for instance, like the
Warren versus Bernie. Right, so Warren was less
good on policy than Bernie, but it would be,
you know, a first woman presidential candidate.
The example I have initially was a friend of mine
did this experiment when she was a teacher in St.
Louis, and this was during the riots down there.
She had all of her students in their
fourth grade class draw, a scientist
and every one of them drew a an older white man.
OK. And all of the students were black, and not
one of them drew a black person. And they were
wondering why. And they were like, Oh, we don't.
That's not something I can do. And they they
weren't aware of any black scientists. So. And
to what degree would you be willing to give in on
some policies, if any, for the sake of, you know,
giving representation to underrepresented groups?
Speaker 1: So I mean, my view on this really
hasn't changed, which is I care about policy
and not identity in terms of making decisions.
But I still recognize the importance of
identity in our understanding of the world.
And so my opposition to identity politics
has been you can't use identity as a cudgel
to silence people to delegitimize voices. And
so that's why I was, for example, so against
when the Women's March said Jewish women weren't
intersectional enough to be on the leadership.
I was completely against that. I found that vile
in my analysis of the 2020 Democratic candidates.
I didn't care about identity at all. I only cared
about policy, etc. at the same time. There is no
understating. The importance and value and
inspiration of, for example, we now have a
female vice president for the first time and it's
the first year there's all these other Dekel.
I don't even know all the categories. I'm so out
of the identity game that I don't even know all
the all the categories that Kamala Harris is part
of, I think. Is it is there the Native American or
Asian? You know, all these different things?
OK? There's no question that for young girls and
young minority girls or all minority
people, whatever, there's value in seeing
that there is now an individual that checks
certain boxes that for the first time is in
this role. There's no need to minimize that. What
I'm against is using identity as a cudgel or as
a weapon. And I don't know if that answers your
question, but I think it's a complicated topic.
Speaker 2: No, I agree. It's it's a super complex,
and I think that's a that's about where I'm at
as well. That was kind of curious because in some
of the videos I had seen, it seemed you were very
much so like against identity politics. But thanks
for the clarification and like, you know, yeah,
Speaker 1: I'm against identity, I'm
against identity politics, but I'm in
favor of recognizing the value of identity and
what it brings to our conversations of things.
Speaker 2: That makes sense.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend,
thank you very much for the call, I
appreciate it. Let's see what else here.
We, by the way, don't don't use my name on our
Discord server. You're going to get banned for
that. So use use a real name, don't don't
say your name is David Pakman. That's not.
We don't allow that. Let's try Zach
from Orlando. Zach, you're on the air.
Zach, from Orlando, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Just barely Zach. Go ahead.
Speaker 2: Yeah, so my question is, as someone
who considers himself pretty far left, I look
at countries like Denmark or Norway, Sweden,
Canada, et cetera, as countries that I would like
the United States to kind of emulate. Mm-Hmm.
And I have a lot of conservative family members.
I'm like the only one that's even left, I
guess. OK. And I never hear them talk about
any other country in a good way. I was
wondering, are there countries that the
United Conservatives praise or think are good?
Speaker 1: You know, I mean, you really have to
ask them. But what's really, really funny is that
for these kind of hardcore Christian Republicans,
the countries that most match their moral values
are radical Islamist countries were that have,
you know, many of them a Christian version
of what many of these Muslim countries have.
And so it's often what they envision as ideal
is like Saudi Arabia, et cetera, even though
they claim not to like those countries. And it's
a very interesting contrast. But you'd really
have to ask them. I don't know what countries
they like. A lot of them say they like, what
do territory has done and cleaning things up and
whatever. You know, we're talking about a dictator
here. You really have to ask them, but there's
some pretty serious hypocrisy there, for sure.
Speaker 2: Of course, yeah. Well,
thank you very much for picking on me,
I didn't think I'd get called on. I appreciate it.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Great to speak to you.
We're going to take a very, very quick break
if you're holding to talk to me. Don't hang up
because we're going to go right back
to the phones momentarily. Stand by.